wir haben ja hier schon öfter darüber
berichtet der wettlauf um den mars hat
begonnen neben moment mal den mond hat
jetzt auch der wettlauf um den mars
bekommen ja jetzt haben jedenfalls die
chinesen konkrete pläne für eine grüne
kolonie auf dem mars vorgestellt konkret
geht es um einen komplett vertikalen
wald wie die kolonie auf dem roten
planeten aussehen soll und wie
realistisch diese idee wirklich ist und
wie ist die lage auf dem mars jetzt den
klicks im science fiction herzlich
willkommen
nicht wenige gehen davon aus dass in
spätestens 100 jahren bäume auf dem mars
wachsen die es dann auch möglich für uns
menschen machen dort zu leben
wir berichten hier ja immer mal wieder
über eine mögliche besiedlung des mars
allen masc mit spacex ist ganz vorne mit
dabei
jetzt hat auch die chinesische
weltraumorganisation pläne zu einer mars
kolonie vorgestellt in zusammenarbeit
mit dem italienischen stararchitekten
stefano boeri soll eine grüne mars
kolonie entstehen mit sogenannten
vertikalen wäldern und dafür ist der
künstler bekannt schon 2014 hat der
architekt das projekt bosco vertikale
abgeschlossen
ein vertikaler wald quasi anders
ausgedrückt zwei begrünte hochhäuser in
mailand und das ist wirklich
beeindruckend das eine haus ist
beispielsweise 27 stockwerke hoch und
misst knapp 120 meter an seinen seiten
wachsen tausende pflanzen hecken
sträucher und auch ganze bäume und das
ist wohl auch in china auf interesse
gestoßen
es folgten mehrere aufträge für bo ehre
unter anderem arbeitet er jetzt daran
einen kompletten chinesischen stadtteil
grün zumachen
laut seinen plänen sollen in der forest
city also waldstadt in der chinesischen
stadt schwaz lang 100.000 menschen leben
können dabei geht es lediglich um eine
fläche von 2 125 quadratkilometer die
unzähligen pflanzen dort sollen seinen
angaben zufolge die lebensqualität der
menschen dort stark verbessern denn
bäume und andere pflanzen würden nicht
nur die luft reinigen sondern würden
auch für eine natürliche dämmert doch
seine künstlerischen projekte wieder
nicht nur auf der erde umsetzen sondern
bald auch im weltraum konkret hat
stefano boeri an einem projekt
mitgearbeitet in dem ideen entwickelt
werden sollten wie wir in 100 jahren
leben könnten
der name des konzepts new shanghai falls
dann der meeresspiegel die erde mehr
oder minder unbewohnbar machen sollte
hat wo er also vorgeschlagen eine art
öko stadt auf dem mars zu bauen den
riesigen versiegelten kuppeln sollen
türme stehen die mit pflanzen bedeckt
sind diese runden hülsen artigen gefäße
sollen zunächst von der erde auf dem
mars gebracht werden und dort dann die
grüne kolonie bildnachweis idee würden
auch wir menschen in diesen kuppeln
leben was für einen
ganze abgeschlossene ökosysteme die wie
eine art samen auf dem roten planeten
gepflanzt werden könnten dieses projekt
ist künstlerisch angehaucht seine
installation kann man mit augmented
reality technologie schon heute hautnah
erleben doch an diesem projekt ist nicht
alles nur kunst tatsächlich sind auch
die tongji universität und die chinesen
raumfahrtbehörde beteiligt doch wie
genau soll das ganze tatsächlich
funktionieren die bedingungen auf dem
mars sind ja nicht gerade der
lebensfreundlich auch wenn der mars der
planet in unserem sonnensystem ist der
der erde am ähnlichsten ist nicht nur
die durchschnittliche temperatur von
minus 56 grad celsius die würde es uns
menschen dort sehr schwer machen zudem
gibt es was ich wenig sauerstoff die
atmosphäre besteht hauptsächlich aus
kohlendioxid und ist etwa 100 mal dünner
als hier auf der erde
spezielle raumanzüge müssten leben auf
dem mars selbst zu dem von der
kosmischen strahlung schützen das sind
also die bedingungen die auf dem roten
planeten vor herrschen und die
zukünftigen kolonien müssten diesen
trotzen wie das genau funktionieren soll
dazu hat sich die chinesische
weltraumorganisation noch nicht konkret
geäußert aber sie haben ja noch 100
jahre zeit um das ganze technisch
umzusetzen realistisch betrachtet ist
die ganze idee derzeit allerdings nicht
mehr als eine kühne vision doch fest
steht china hat große pläne und alles
sieht bislang danach aus als würden die
chinesen dem westen in sachen weltraum
schon bald den rang ablaufen schauen wir
mal wenn er kein video zur entwicklung
der raumfahrt und auch zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich
den genau auf die glocke nur dann
verpasst sie auch wirklich kein video
hier geht es weiter mit dem video zum
thema helium-3 abbau auf dem mond durch
wen wohl china sehr sehr spannendes
thema und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran